welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead season 11 episode 17.
That's right The Walking Dead is back
for the final part of its final season
and we start off with some flashback
Montage yes it's Rick Grimes as his
daughter Judith Grimes narrates a little
retrospective but now in the present we
skip for now the Cliffhanger at
Oceanside with Lance Hornsby flipping
his Two-Face coin We Begin later that
day as Lance horns be in the
Commonwealth Stormtroopers are hunting
down our crew in the Commonwealth
outskirts now we know Lance hornsby's
actions out here aren't officially
sanctioned he's basically gone Rogue but
this group doesn't really know that
there's a lot of uncertainty about
what's happening back at the
Commonwealth if Lance Hornby radioed
back they'd all be shot on site except
for someone he's never seen before Negan
and so Negan with his new Whispers kills
oh he's on the loose headed to the
Commonwealth it actually turns into a
big car chase meanwhile Daryl Dixon's
having a shootout with the Troopers and
yeah they've never gone against our crew
before in the end boom big car crash and
Negan is out of here at the Commonwealth
it's big protest day remember our crew
just wrote the expose that Sebastian
Milton was sending poor people to their
deaths and Milton covered it up Governor
Pamela Milton's doing the classic deny
everything response but she's not hiding
Sebastian right now actually he's hiding
from her she doesn't know where he is
but now negan's made it inside says hi
to his old friend Carol he fills her in
about Lance Hornsby trying to kill their
friends outside so Carol has a plan to
protect all their people they need
leverage they need to find Sebastian
Milton meanwhile Hornsby has not been
able to radio back to the Commonwealth
yet they can't get a good signal the
only word that came through Was Daryl
Dixon so a couple of his CIA agents raid
their apartment where Carol's been
babysitting the kids oh and so it's up
to our favorite minor character Jerry to
take the kids on a little field trip to
his secret at a kaido eventually Pamela
Milton is sick of all this protesting
she calls a lockdown because a zombie
horde is coming right now everyone
thinks it's a little convenient so they
keep protesting and the Stormtroopers
got a tear gas them but turns out there
really is a zombie horde coming right
now so General Mercer grabs Rosita and a
bunch of Stormtroopers to go off and
fight him and the Commonwealth is
normally very good at handling these
things but everything's messed up today
they're having some trouble these two
doofuses somehow managed to flip their
Jeep so Mercer's gotta run to save him
with Rosita on the gun meanwhile Carol
and Negan and are on the hunt for
Sebastian Milton and pretty soon they
find his secret bachelor pad Panic Room
as they're getting him out of there
though someone recognizes him so negan's
got to stay behind to run interference
while Carol takes him out yumiko by the
way is in Pamela Milton's Inner Circle
now she's kind of her lawyer but Pamela
Milton's starting not to trust her now
because she realizes she's friends with
Khan either reporter who probably wrote
the article now Carol shows up like hey
Governor found your son and they got the
interesting mother-son relationship
where she hugs him but then slaps him
like a kid you put us in such a pickle
but Carol's like hey I think I can help
I'm kind of a professional Problem
Solver Lance hornsby's gone Rogue out
there killing my friends I need him
stopped and if you want to cover for
Sebastian you need a different scapegoat
blame it all on Hornsby but meanwhile
Daryl Maggie and the outside gang are
still hiding from him it's negan's new
pregnant wife who has the idea to hide
in the sewers and lure them down into a
trap but it's a double trap when more
Stormtroopers pop out but it's a Triple
Trap when more of our crew pops out than
a quadruple trap when even more
Stormtroopers pop out so with these guys
in a quadruple trap stalemate that's
where episode 17 comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]